thousands of people have been killed or
injured after a 7.8 magnitude earthquake
and major aftershocks hit turkey and
Syria so how did it happen and why was
it so bad
[Music]
well first of all this earthquake was
very powerful magnitude 7.8 turkey
hasn't seen an earthquake of similar
magnitude since 1939 then there was a
second Aftershock almost as powerful as
the first both of those earthquakes were
quite shallow and that means more of the
energy of the earthquake will be felt at
the surface where it can damage
structures and infrastructure
and then there's the vulnerability of
buildings themselves turkey upgraded its
earthquake building codes after a major
earthquake in the northwest of the
country in 1999 but buildings predating
those codes or those built with
substandard materials or not built so
well could have been vulnerable
turkey and Northern Syria are earthquake
prone they sit where three major
tectonic plates meet and a smaller
tectonic plate the Anatolian plate is
being pushed westwards by the African
plate that's driving up towards the
north about two centimeters a year and
that's putting pressure on a slip fault
called the East Anatolian fault which is
where this earthquake happened it's
probably been suddenly released to cause
this earthquake in fact there hasn't
been a major earthquake on the East
Anatolian fault since the 1870s suggests
a lot of pressure has been building up
that was suddenly released to cause this
major earthquake
[Music]
typically major earthquakes are followed
by a series of aftershocks but they tend
to be diminishing magnitude and
frequency as time goes by what's highly
unusual about this earthquake is there
was an after shot of similar magnitude
to the initial earthquake with epicenter
100 kilometers north of the first major
earthquake
[Music]
offers of help and rescue teams from
around Europe including the UK are
making their way to Turkey but they face
an enormous challenge because of the
size of this earthquake the fact has
happened in quite a populated area and
also these major aftershocks will have
given a very wide Geographic spread to
the impact of this earthquake disaster
typically in these situations roads and
other infrastructure get damaged which
means getting around is hard
Communications can be difficult as 4G
networks get overwhelmed it's also cold
in parts of turkey at the moment
nighttime temperatures around the
epicenter we're down to minus four last
night that's going to make rescue
efforts harder but also make their
efforts much more urgent as they need to
get to survivors in these freezing
temperatures